foreign
millibyte megabyte
it was a four megabyte video
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the price
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango
es
don't you want me to me
if highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're just joining us Rudy Giuliani
is sweating his face off explaining to
us why Trump really won the election
again inspectors every state
almost every approve this
it's going away go on for eternity is
this a skit the only thing left is to
prevent a dead person that could have
been not filled out probably but he's
saying there was a dead person in the
envelope
Rudy's about to have actual drops of
sweat coming off of his brow I mean is
this a normal amount I don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here we'll be in the
lawsuit that comes out dude he's melting
Arizona is a state that we're looking at
very very carefully strongly looking at
it I would say we're probably I assume
oh my God she's working if she's working
for this
I'd like to read a multi but I don't
have the time
you should have had the time and energy
to go look for them
that's your job
like it's my job to defend the president
explained Michigan Wisconsin is he
bleeding did you see is he bleeding from
his ear what on Earth
[Music]
is that hair dye is to look at the
lawsuits in order to do it it looks like
blood but in the material oh my God it's
everywhere
thousand at least and we're getting he's
gotta get off the stage and there are
other aspects of this fraud on the
morning of November someone's got to get
him a napkin they were going to count
the these this new kind of job I've
never seen anything like this what on
Earth it's getting onto his shirt now
Michigan and in Wisconsin any jury would
accept because they heard this evidence
that somebody had this plan
maybe that was always the plan
looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup to the city describe that
to you oh my God it's all over his face
I don't know guys it's sounding like
Trump won isn't it based on this
all right welcome everybody you know one
of the things I don't know why I find it
so funny
but every single time I stream when our
intro thing is up this thing
people on both twitch and YouTube start
going
David the video's Frozen it's like no
it's not guys it hasn't started yet no
sound
anyone else getting sound
David you're muted
I'm not there
the stream hasn't started yet it's like
every single time it happened
anybody else getting video like no
it's just still it's like you know I
mean come on guys okay all right good by
the way the mango song reminded me
um
I ha I bought a mango over the weekend
wait no when did I buy I bought the
mango
no I bought the mango eight days ago and
I've just been letting it ripen it's
still not ripening you know it's
supposed to just give a little bit and
smell like mango at the stem end
it's starting to all it's like it's
skipped ripeness and part of it's
getting a little wrinkled it's very
weird
um it's I I would actually blame it on
Biden that I have a non-ripening mango
uh
very very strange and also I was able to
get my Granny Smiths today so that
that's all happening guys I have so many
things to announce and so many things to
go over first and foremost at the bottom
of the hour not not up there down there
at the bottom of the hour
um
at the bottom of the hour up under the
Biden regime Joe Biden is going to make
a an announcement about the
infrastructure bill that's number one
number two the stock market has
collapsed again another crash okay
um down another 650 the Dow up a little
bit yesterday recovering from the nearly
thousand Point decline this was the big
decline up a little and then now down
even lower believed to be because of
Omicron or even because of omnicron it's
called the omnicron exactly omnicron
right so thanks to small fuzzy Moss for
those additional
um audio uh elements there but uh so now
we've got another day of declines so
that's the other thing and then number
three there has been another of these
mass shootings and we have some clips
from it that we're going to be looking
at in a moment a lot of different things
happening so quite quite quite an agenda
today
and where where to even begin I do want
to thank amazing people who are here
including colder durs I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly Emily G
under H2O diver for the twitch Prime
subscriptions I appreciate that you can
also use the coupon code Obama Obama
to get a membership on my website all
new members will be announced and in
fact I have one here to announce
and their name is
eleven dollar mango
new member eleven dollar mango has
signed up with the coupon code obamna
Obama his new member number Governor Tim
Walls senator Amy Klobuchar
Senator Tina Smith and congresswoman
Angie Craig all right so we're gonna
we're gonna wait for uh for Joe Biden
there
um let's see a couple other things I do
have a new another new audio element
which I really like
um yesterday I played for you guys wow
what an agenda it's been a long time
since we had such a packed agenda
yesterday I played for you this clip of
me at a deli over the weekend
[Music]
okay so two corned beefs on Pumpernickel
with sauerkraut small fuzzy Moss has now
turned it into an audio element for me
[Music]
so now we have that and I think it would
work well mixed in with some of this
stuff by the way how are the calzones
uncharged piccolos but we have Subway
tomorrow pizza is here okay
oh wait and I forgot my favorite oh my
KFC oh what happened to my KFC something
happened
um all right anyway so uh we have that
so let's see we can't we've got we've
taken care of that I think that that's
gonna be good
um oh thank you to chlo main for the
twitch Prime subscription
um it is the third day of Hanukkah for
everybody celebrating that means let me
see okay day one you do one candle
day two you do two candles so today we
do three candles three candles
um it's the third night sorry I always
do that it's the third night of Hanukkah
tonight
yeah not we don't go by days we go by
nights I I apologize for that
um okay later on we're gonna be playing
a new game called pokemane or Hassan
then that's the name of the game I'm not
even gonna tell you how it's played yet
but the name of the game is pokemane or
Hassan that's gonna be a little bit
later
a few super chats coming in ferret queen
says the U.S is four and a quarter
percent of the world's population 18 of
the coveted cases and 15 of the deaths
exactly right
exactly right
um thank you to chess Boyardee for the
twitch Prime subscription very much
appreciate that you are truly too kind
um people are already saying pokemane or
Hassan I haven't even explained the
rules of the game yet
uh which is really wild I have a couple
of new oh here's another tell me if you
guys think I should have this on my
soundboard this is from a clip that we
just published
um me I there's one point in a clip
today where I list types of beans and
another where I I list types of pasta
um tell me if you think we need this on
the sound board you couldn't find black
beans you couldn't find pinto beans you
couldn't find kidney beans you couldn't
find cannellini beans you couldn't find
refried beans you couldn't find spicy
refried beans you couldn't find fava
beans okay I could go on I'm all right
so that's what that's one part where
that could be a clip for itself okay and
then here is another part where you guys
tell me whether this should be a clip
um the dry pasta section
empty no spaghetti no ziti no penne no
gnocchi no pepper deli no rotini
linguine angel hair cavatappi
tagliatelli fusilli macaroni farfalle
conchiglier
you couldn't find lasagna noodles guys
okay uh all right so I'm gonna suggest
two different mimetic layers okay now
different different levels of expertise
are required to participate memetic
layer one
is simply we put that on the sound board
okay and I think we can do that pretty
quickly mimetic Layer Two is remixing
that into a rap song
and that that's almost like layer five
because that would just be incredible so
if any of our remixers like office
akimov or officer akimov Jethro Bradley
um uh Joe Woodward anybody wants to do
that uh I think that that would be
something else to look at I want to say
thanks to Andrew Walters who just signed
up on my website using the coupon code
Obama Obama very much appreciate that
um
okay so we dealt with that
uh let me see what else I have that's
quick because Joe Biden might speak at
any time here
um
I actually don't really have anything
else that's too too quick
let's see what this one is no I don't
want to do that no that's for later
oh yeah okay let's look at this one this
is so this is the new thing now on Biden
they've moved on from dementia to he has
some other kind of illness decision
every single time I think they also
um Mr Biden I don't know if it strikes
you but even when he spoke yesterday uh
he's still sniffling he still his horse
this is somebody who's he's a horse weak
and I almost feel like those around him
perceive him as weak and they're trying
to enact what their uh political uh
inclinations are and we know that that's
been the argument all along is that Mr
Biden ran as a moderate and he's got all
right so I don't know how running is a
moderate has to do with him being hoarse
and sniffling that being said it's not
wrong that it is absolutely accurate
that Biden has been sniffling
he has had some kind of voice issue and
is coughing a lot it's been going on for
weeks and weeks we're told it's a cold
um
that that's what we're told I mean if we
have evidence of something else then
certainly we should know about it let's
put it that way we should certainly
could be allergic an allergy although
winter I don't know about winter
allergies I don't know about that
but in any case
um I do want to say thanks to
pack oh boy this is a very aggressive
new member new member Pac mangoes deep
in my papaya has signed up on my website
with the coupon code Obama
and his new member number eight today I
really do appreciate that I know that
new member as Juan but they want to be
known as that other thing I said so
that's fine uh if that's if that's what
they want we I I will oblige that a
little strange but all right hello Moro
says David's production value is
appreciated thank you
I appreciate that very very much
um we are standing by for Joe Biden and
we have a ton of other stuff to look at
today
um so I hope that uh
everybody will will stand by we may talk
about Ivermectin we may talk about
Ivermectin but I'm not totally sure yet
uh let's listen to a little bit of
what's Happening Here jobs union jobs
it is going to boost
it's gonna boost the economies and the
communities where these students live
and work and if you're worried about
Workforce shortages if that's a problem
all right so we're really going to focus
in on the Joe Biden a piece of it some
of you will find very very interesting
that now as the jillane some people say
jizzling that I I can't imagine that's
the right name I'm told it's gileen
jelane Maxwell's trial is underway and
as a result Jeffrey Epstein's airplane
pilot testified today
and identified Donald Trump as a
passenger on the Epstein Jet and William
Jefferson Clinton as a passenger on the
jet as well as others said he did not
witness any sex acts but it's very funny
because yesterday Lauren bobert started
saying the left is very worried about
the gilaine Maxwell trial it's like
Trump Trump's literally on the plane so
is Clinton I don't think it is a left
right thing I think that there are a lot
of people who potentially are going to
be exposed uh by by this trial but Trump
and Clinton among the famous people on
the Epstein Jet and I would be worried I
would be worried uh as far as if I if I
were certain people I would at least
theoretically be worried that it's not
going to go so well in this trial
David did you read the article stating
how the USA is becoming a backsliding
democracy yes I have a video clip on it
which you can check out from last week
I want to say thanks to Nick Lovin as
well as Apocrypha new members 9 and 10
via twitch Prime today
we will open phone lines if we get to
100 this is the last opportunity to open
phone lines for the month mostly because
at least on the East Coast uh there's
only seven and a half hours left in the
month that's that's really what it's
driven by oh speaking of which I do want
to let everybody know because there was
such interest last time we've scheduled
the next viewer Town Hall I would love
all of you to at minimum watch if not
call in so just like last time the David
Pacman show viewer tip please write this
down so that I don't get the same
questions about it okay
viewer Town Hall when
December 14th 2021 that's the when
what time 6 PM Eastern
that's it it's not on any other day and
it's not at any other time
December 14th 6 PM Eastern where only
the Pac-Man Live YouTube channel we are
now dangerously close to 15 000
subscribers on the new channel okay
you can find all of the latest clips
from the live streams on the Pac-Man
Live Channel that's the only place it
will be streaming so when 6 PM December
14th
where the Pac-Man Live YouTube channel
who can participate everybody okay it
will be via Discord we are going to have
one uh channel for everybody who wants
to call in
we will have an additional channel for
members members get special handling
it's sort of like when you have status
with an airline and they drive you to
the plane in a Porsche Porsche Porsche
I'm not even sure how it's pronounced
anyway or an Audi
um there will be so if you do sign up on
my website you are quite literally more
than twice as likely to be able to get
on
Porsche Porsche that can't be right
um okay so that's just another benefit
of signing up on my website but I'm very
much looking forward to it the first one
we did we we took close to like 70 calls
um and it was tremendous it was just
fantastic
uh Brandon from St Louis says David when
is the next viewer town hall and where
can we watch it that's a really good
question very very good question
um
preemptively submitting my first answer
as Hassan okay thanks to regional
manager Vader for the twitch Prime
subscription it is great to be back on
Twitch we love being on Twitch we love
being on Twitch and it's really great to
be on
um
all sorts of questions will be allowed
Financial questions
um food related questions political
questions cultural film television books
any all questions are welcome I may have
no answer for some of the questions but
questions are allowed
the questions will be allowed
um
man a lot of really strange people in
the chat today
very very strange
okay before we continue forward I I
think it's probably just a moment before
actually this may be Joe Biden coming up
now
this is just the beginning of the stream
guys because we have so much happening
hmm
okay
ah
they need to put that thing on they're
very good um in the meantime we'll
listen to a voicemail or two here is
Eric from Mass with another anti-vax
screed
hey David Eric from math uh it's
undeniable now Forbes magazine or Forbes
online or whatever just came out and
said whatever yeah the vaccine change of
DNA look it up try and deny that try and
deny all the other stuff
so you have different DNA now because
hey get out some more boosters dude
boosters get your boosters dude yeah I
got my booster it was if it was it was
pretty good actually Eggman called in
hi guys regarding the man that shot and
killed his young daughter in a hunting
accident he should be completely charged
with murder 100 murder wow thank you I
have no further comment on that
but if you want further comment on that
how do we know what was going through
the guy's mind you know maybe he feared
for his life maybe it was just
self-defense me he hated his daughter
she was ruining his life he wanted to
divorce the daughter's mom that kid was
in the way always in trouble rooting his
relationship maybe he was on purpose we
do not know why he murdered that little
girl true because of that he needs to be
charged we never know what's in the mind
of the guy that brings an AK and murders
BLM guys you don't know what he was
thinking but this guy I'm sure his
thoughts were absolutely pure right oh
he was a white guy too by the way right
I'm sure that had to bring that in okay
I hope he didn't play this horrible
message Shalom guys
Colombian Soylent oh my God the Eggman
just completely shot out of a cannon
today not even he must be on something
something uh maybe like a triple shot of
something it's wild
um let's see
in Pac-Man
when are you gonna have Andrew Nick on
your show
talk about artificial intelligence
yikes
yikes all right we'll do I guess we'll
do one Whitney voicemail
shut your video or something
like so many voicemails that might have
been like way more relevant
um all right let's get back to Joe Biden
elements of medical
foreign
[Applause]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is Sarah herzon and I'm a first
year student here at Dakota County
Technical College
I'm in the heavy construction equipment
technology program and I'm working
towards my associate's degree
I grew up in Eden Prairie and graduated
from Minnetonka High School in 2019 or
2018. sorry my bad a little about myself
I enlisted in the Minnesota Army
National Guard on my 17th birthday and
ironically one of my favorite things is
when Biden urges everybody to sit the
hell down
[Music]
I was deployed in October 2019 where I
spent 13 months in Kuwait while I was
deployed I worked on all of our large
Vehicles as well as all the power
generation and AC equipment with being
the only 91 Delta Tactical power
generation specialist I oversaw the
maintenance over of 400 power generation
and AC units I also cross-trained the
whole time on all the vehicles such as
the Humvees the lmtvs fmtvs helmets
everything that you could think of that
does not have tracks
when I returned from deployment I was
wondering now what what should I do with
my life now I started looking for a
program that I could utilize my military
experience as well as what I've known
since growing up right
and I found Dakota County Technical
College right in my backyard
my journey at DCTC started in January as
part of the heavy construction equipment
program this semester we are learning
how to fix electrical issues on the
equipment applied failure analysis shop
safety engine overhaul as well as
welding this program has given me the
opportunity to receive an internship at
caterpillar which I am so great yeah I
would be more interested in military
grade hummus rather than Hummers I would
want to know what are they doing to make
it so powerful and hire on a whole
female team I want
I want to serve as a garlic for women
that we too can be in the trades
with
with having this degree as well as my
military experience and heavy equipment
it will set me ahead of others in my
field
I am so happy to have this opportunity
to welcome President Joe Biden to my
home state as well as my school Dakota
County Technical College thank you so
much anything
[Music]
whoa
Sarah thank you for the introduction
I was saying to Sarah in the back
because I when I was Sarah's age the
idea
that I'd be standing waiting to
introduce a president no matter who it
was I would find a little daunting and I
was trying to reassure but obviously she
didn't need any reassurance whatsoever
zero
and thank you for your service to the
United States military
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for the welcome to Minnesota
I was telling the governor on the way in
the ride here from the airport that I
started coming to Minnesota back in
1973 because one of my mentors for real
one of it ended up being two was Hubert
Humphrey when I uh he helped me campaign
in 1972 as a 29 year old candidate for
the United States Senate my home state
of Delaware and he gave me credibility
I'm not sure I deserve but it helped a
great deal
and after I got elected there was a
before I was I wasn't old enough to be
sworn in I had to wait to be eligible
you have to be 30 years old to be sworn
in your your constituents can elect you
at any age but you can't be sworn into
30.
and while I was in Washington
making sure that I was hiring my staff
I got a phone call from my fire
department saying there'd been an
accident it used to be some kind of
audio issue on the phone I had to say
she just blurted out your wife and
daughter are dead and your kids won't
make it my wife was Christmas shopping
it was broadsided by a tractor trailer
my point about it is that one of the
first persons that come to me were the
Humphreys not just the senator
and uh and then a guy who became a great
friend and Mentor was uh like isn't
there a crazy Reverb as well so I've
been from the Iron Range all the way
down here Southern Southeastern border
and uh it's an incredible State and
they've been elected some incredible
people including the people you heard
from earlier today which I'll speak to a
little bit in a minute
um the uh I see a lot of Mayors are here
um and uh you know I told you that's the
toughest job in America they know where
you live
[Music]
but it really is you affect people's
lives more than anybody else it reminds
me of this
are incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they
held it
[Applause]
actually served in Congress for a long
time and I'm delighted I'm delighted uh
for uh him being here before I get into
my remarks and any detail I was informed
after the tour I learned about a school
shooting in Michigan
we learned well as we learned the full
details my heart goes out to the
families and during the unimaginable
grief of losing a loved one apparently
there is somewhere in the order of nine
people shot and several or three I think
are dead and the young man I think is as
I understand it from staff is about 15
years old and he uh he turned himself in
and uh just said and he claimed his uh
right against self-incrimination and
handed over his pistol that's all we
know about it but you've got to know
that that whole Community has to be just
in a State of Shock right now
but look uh one of the things that I
want to mention is I want to tell you
about the infrastructure law I signed on
Thanksgiving
and it would not be possible this is not
hyperbole without the Minnesota
Congressional Delegation Senator Senator
a b Klobuchar was a leader in many
issues her colleagues looked at her on
everything from lowering the cost of
prescription drugs to how to get
Broadband I don't find these speeches
super inspiring either I will I'm with a
lot of the audience on that and I listen
I choose this over Trump any day
[Music]
and not only do her colleagues call for
advice her president
and you know that's true
and uh and Senator Tina Smith she's also
LED on making sure that minnesotans and
all Americans get access to access
access to high-speed internet Senator
Smith is making sure that the
infrastructure and build back better
Investments were going to help fight
both the causes and the effects of
climate change and
thank you
[Music]
Representatives Angie Craig who I'm
going to get to ride home with she's
going to get an Air Force One with going
back spending that time
she had a better means of transportation
getting out here I don't know what it
was but but all goodness that's kind of
funny we've worked she's worked in
infrastructure law she constantly
reminds us
that it's places like Dakota County and
that's connecting people to jobs and
opportunities and that's why Angie has
always been a champion of schools like
DCTC and investments in roads and
bridges and high-speed internet and
representative Dean Phillips
[Music]
Dean from the very beginning Dean has
led getting
bipartisan support to get this deal done
and you'd think this would be a slam
dunk but we did it without
all but a few Republicans being able to
come across and vote for it but thank
you for the work you did and I really
mean it
[Applause]
[Music]
fighting for strong infrastructure
package for more than a little bit of
time there you are Betty and uh but I
also want to acknowledge
a few other people who couldn't be here
today your attorney general Ellison is a
such a fighter for justice and
representative Omar is he here
yeah
[Music]
oh okay I was gonna say I totally
wouldn't remind us we all need to invest
in our people and Universal pre-care and
affordable child care
look at what this is all about
rebuilding America
getting this done now rebuilding in
America investing in America that's what
this is about
and we're doing it as we continue to
battle the pandemic
as I told the American people yesterday
this new variant is the audio concern
but not a cause to panic on Thursday
I'll put forward a detailed strategy
outlining how we've gone we're going to
fight this covid this winter not with
shutdowns and lockdowns with more
widespread vaccination boosters testing
and much more in the meantime
didn't you be threatening people's jobs
over the audience getting fully
vaccinated
getting a booster shot
[Applause]
I urge all Americans who haven't yet to
get that done get it done today
we're going to keep fighting through
this and every tool we have and we are
you know as we did with the original
virus and with the Delta virus very very
and we're also going to keep our
historic economic growth moving one of
the ways we're going to do that is with
the bipartisan infrastructure law that
we signed into law two weeks ago over
the next several weeks I'm going to be
traveling all over the country and so
will vice president Harris and my
cabinet and folks throughout this our
Administration to show how these
Investments are going to change your
lives change lives for the better
because we know that we can't just build
back to what it was before that used to
be the rule if anything got wiped out by
a weather event you're able to build
back that road to exactly the
specifications it was before but you
can't now because the climate's not
going to get better and hopefully we're
not going to get worse but you're going
to have to build that road a couple feet
higher you can't build it back to what
it was you can't replace those high
power lines and come down with the same
kind of construction they have to be
built so they're more resilient build
them back better I mean when I say build
back better right it's necessary and you
know schools like DCTC are going to help
us do just that
places like this we're going to train
the next generation of workers to do the
jobs that my infrastructure law and our
build back better act are going to put
into even greater demand we're going to
need more qualified people and we're
talking about students learning how to
repair electric vehicles and Battery
drivetrains which are our major auto
manufacturers say will be 40 to 50
percent of all vehicles in the United
States of America by the year 2030.
let's hope becoming line workers will
need to have to modernize our electric
grid and Commercial electricians who can
who can help us install 500 000 electric
vehicle charging stations we're going to
put in including along the highways
we're building so you never have to
worry about running out of power to be
able to travel
that I'm behind training is construction
managers to oversee All Phases of
construction projects we're going to be
seeing all across Minnesota like the
twin Port interchange and ports
interchange in Duluth and the link
project in Rochester
these two jobs of the day and tomorrow
we're going to help America win the
competition of the 21st century we're
getting back in the game
and the better part of the 20th century
for the better part we led the World by
a significant margin because we invested
in ourselves and our people we invested
in our infrastructure and our roads our
highways our bridges our ports our
airports the arteries of our nation that
allow Commerce to function smoothly and
move swiftly
and we've uh We've invested we invested
in our people we invested an opportunity
in the past but we're among we were
among the first to provide access to
free education in the late 1800s early
1900s which had us leap ahead of the
rest of the world the first nation in
the world with universal education we
invested to win the Space Race we led
the world in research and development
that led the creation of the internet
and but somewhere along the way we
stopped investing
and we're at risk of losing our Edge as
a nation to China and the rest of the
world that's catching up and surpassing
Us in some areas our infrastructure used
to be rated the best in the world not
hyperbole was rated the best in the
world but according to the world
economic Forum we now rank 13th in the
world in terms of the quality of our
infrastructure
and we're turning things around in a big
way now it starts with rows and bridges
in 2007 this says this state sounded the
national arm of our decaying
infrastructure when the I-35 bridge
collapsed killing 13 people under
another 140.
in the United States of America
a major Vision on how it collapsed
this is America for God's sake
and we know about our infrastructure
problems we've known it for a long time
now we're finally doing something about
it no more talking Time for Action
terrific action
right
[Music]
this law makes significant investments
in our roads and bridges and the largest
investment nearly 70 years
fix it so many of the 661 Bridges nearly
5 000 miles of Highway here in Minnesota
just Minnesota that are in poor
condition
those decaying roads cost Minnesota
drivers an extra 543 dollars a year in
gas repairs and longer commute times
every family that's 543 hidden dollars
in Hidden taxes for Minnesota families
and by the way we might even be able to
get something done fixing County Road 42
train crossing are we good
we have one in Delaware
we have a train crossing we used to be
the General Motors plant I've counted as
many 142 cars sitting there for about 10
hours waiting to cross No Way Out look
this law includes the most significant
investment of Passenger rail in the past
50 years and in public transportation
ever as
so that means replacing Transit vehicles
that are past a useful life switching
from diesel to Electric getting more
people where they have to go it's safer
safer faster and cleaner and it means
more projects like the orange line which
is having this grand opening on Saturday
and it's connecting communities all
along I-35 West with bus Rapid Transit
making it easier and faster to commute
from Burnsville to Bloomberg and to
assuming to Bloomington to Richville
to to major job centers in downtown
Minnesota and Minneapolis Minnesota the
corporate headquarters like the U.S bank
and Best Buy and Target
it's going to change that
this law invests the 42 billion dollars
to modernize our ports and our airports
the port of Duluth is the largest port
in the Great Lakes
or the Minneapolis-St Paul Airport one
of the busiest airports in the midwest
make it easy for companies to get Goods
to Market reducing supply chain products
lowering costs for families making sure
that what you need gets to you ships
your trucks and trains and eventually
your home on time
of course that's not always law achieves
the law will start to replace 100
percent of the nation's lead pipes in
the United States American services
the recent survey estimated there are
260
000 or more lead pipelines just here in
Minnesota
just Minnesota
and will help communities like Coast
build connections to water treatment
facilities so every single child
in Minnesota and across America you can
turn on a faucet and drink clean water
without their parents worrying about how
forever chemicals you ever think you'd
hear that phrase 20 years ago forever
chemicals
are in the ground how they're impacting
on the health and what we would have
heard it if the corporations are pumping
them out hadn't covered up their own
research overdue
we're going to need tens of thousands of
plumbers and pipefitters do the work
and they get paid a prevailing wage with
benefits
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the law is going to make high-speed
internet affordable and available
everywhere in America and create jobs
laying down those Broadband lines today
12 percent of minnesotans and households
don't have internet subscriptions and in
some places there's no broadband
infrastructure at all
this law is going to make high speed
internet affordable and available
everywhere in Minnesota Urban suburban
and rural
over 20 billion dollars
the 21st century in America no parent
ever should have to sit outside a fast
food restaurant
to be able to hook up to the Internet so
their child can do their homework online
think about that
who also builds up our resilience
against extreme weather events which
Minnesota is no stranger to like
wildfires this summer in Superior
national forests that sends smoke into
the Twin Cities and tornadoes that
touched down and in Burnsville and Apple
Valley in September or the heavy rains
that have closed roads and contaminated
wells in this area in the past
nationally nationally last year extreme
weather cost the United States
government
99 billion dollars just last year
I was out one of those forest fires out
in California and Nevada area
and it's astounding more
Timber and homes and business have been
burnt to the ground
this past Fire season then the entire
square miles of the state of New Jersey
from New York City all the way down to
Cape May that's how much burned to the
ground
nothing there I flew over in helicopters
nothing
and you see reservoirs down 40 50 60
feet
worrying about where the Colorado River
is going to continue to flow
this is dire stuff
but all within our capacity to deal with
this law builds back our bridges our
water systems our power lines our
electric grid better and stronger more
resilient and resistant to the negative
impacts and effects of climate change
so few Americans will be flooded out of
their homes or lose power for days and
weeks after a storm down in Louisiana I
have with me who now works with me and
handles a big chunk of what I have to do
former chairman of the black caucus in
the Congress Cedric Richmond
[Applause]
sugar cabinet down down in in Louisiana
New Orleans that storm that hurricane
went through had high wind Peak at 178
miles per hour
but you know what when I went from there
up to North Jersey and New York
more people died in Men in Queens
Manhattan because of 20 inches of rain
falling and their basements flooding so
they couldn't get out more people died
there
than did in the hurricane in New Orleans
folks there's so much more in the law
most of all this law does something
truly historic it's going to help
rebuild the backbone of this nation
working people in the middle class when
I ran for the president I said I was
running for three reasons one to restore
the soul of the country to have some
restore some decency
and two
two
to rebuild the backbone of the country
hard-working middle class folks and
world-class folks who built the country
the folks in Wall Street aren't bad but
they didn't build America
the people who work on come out of the
school the ones that build America
they build America and they've been left
behind for much too long
we're going to rebuild this economy from
the bottom up in the middle out
I've never known
I've never known a time when the middle
class has done well at the very wealth
they haven't done very very well true
I'm not being solicitous I'm being
deadly earnest
but I'm tired of this trickle-down
economy
I'm tired of it
this is a blue-collar blueprint to
rebuild America
and the only way this works is if the
blue collar Americans do the building
that's the only way it's ever worked
we're going to do it again mark my worms
mark my words the same goes from my plan
to build back better for our people for
example the cost of a two-year degree in
Minnesota is nearly six thousand dollars
a year over a third of the students at
DCTC receive Pell Grants
my build back better plan is going to
increase the maximum Pell Grant award by
another 550 dollars
to make it more affordable
[Music]
we're going to invest an unprecedented
10 billion dollars in job training
program a school like schools like this
one and expand registered
apprenticeships and pre-apprenticeship
programs
and
very importantly this bill will deliver
Universal preschool to every three and
four-year-old in America
foreign
[Applause]
that the low-income children
participated in a preschool program were
47 percent more likely to go on and earn
an associate or a higher degree after a
grinding through 12 years of school
without problems
we have to
the foundation for success
my wife Jill is a community college
professor and has been for some time
she always points out any nation that
out educates us is going to out-compete
us it's a simple proposition
look what the rest of the world is doing
look who the rest of the world is doing
China Investing billions of dollars in
Early Education I can go down the list
look this build back better plan is also
going to ensure that parents can afford
child care
and the child care work
and their child care workers can
actually get a raise and a raise they
deserve and more education
if you're paying fourteen thousand
dollars for child care like a lot of
Minnesota families do
my build back better plan is going to
make it a giant difference in your life
because your child care costs will not
be will be capped at seven percent of
your income seven percent
that's it seven percent of your income
that's going to make a huge difference
for the economy overall but for millions
of workers had to drop out of the
workforce not because they wanted to
because they couldn't find available
Child Care especially the 2 million
women who left the workforce during this
coven crisis
if you're one of the millions of
Americans paying too much for insulin my
build back better plan's going to change
that as well
because we're going to lower
prescription drug costs and that means
you won't pay more than 35 dollars a
month for your insulin it's important
not only from a health standpoint from a
standpoint of personal dignity imagine
if you're a parent
of one of the 200 000 children
in this country with type 1 diabetes
needing that insulin
insulin can cost as much as one thousand
dollars a month
if you can't afford it
it's not only a health risk but to
deprives the parent of their dignity
surprising of their dignity
of your ability to do the one thing
every parent wants and deserves to be
able to do to say to their child look in
there and say honey it's going to be
okay
imagine not being able to say that
and by the way we're not artificially
reducing that cost it costs 35 dollars
for the insulin when it was first
invented and patented
they've done not a single thing since
then to improve and it's good
get back now it costs a thousand dollars
a month
folks lowering the cost of child care
Elder Care housing Health Care
prescription drugs and meeting the
moment of climate change that's what
this plan does
frankly I'm surprised that not a single
Republican in Congress has joined us in
supporting it
can't be because it would add to
inflation 17 Nobel laureates 17.
three weeks ago spontaneously sent me a
letter
saying that it would have the opposite
effect it would actually reduce
long-term inflationary pressures
it can't be because it would add to the
deficit because reduces the deficit over
the long term
it can't be because it's fiscally
responsible because it's fully paid for
fully patient
no one
no one earning less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year
will pay a single penny more in federal
taxes
55 I come from the corporate state of
America Delaware
more corporations are Incorporated in
Delaware than every other nation in the
in every other excuse me state in the
nation
yeah I've been reading about New Mexico
for LLCs
The Fortune 500 companies the largest
ones
paid zero in income taxes last year
after making 40 billion dollars in
profits
I'm a capitalist
if you can make a million or a billion
dollars have at it
just pay your fair share
that's all the Masters
that's why the build back better plan
has a minimum tax that makes sure the
large profitable corporations start
paying their fair share
and we got passed internationally at
provisioned that a 15 minimum is paid in
every single country so you don't have
countries fleeing here with technology
to go other places because they have a
lower tax rate
the first major piece of legislation in
more than a decade that's not only fully
paid for
based on official estimates from the
Congressional budget office The Joint
Committee on taxation the treasury
Department it's going to generate more
than 100 billion dollars in deficit
reduction this decade
so look I know some people have said
this bill isn't fiscally responsible
enough
because even though it's fully paid for
they acknowledge even though it would
reduce the deficit which they
acknowledge even though it represents
the first time in over a decade that
we're doing the hard work of offsetting
Investments with new Revenue
some of the programs may get extended
and if they get extended they say it's
going to cost more money we didn't count
that in
well that's true Congress is going to
pay for those as well
after years Republican leadership in
Washington passing tax giveaways to the
super wealthy
new spending without even giving a
thought about how to pay for it they
added eight trillion dollars to the
national debt with a trump tax cut eight
trillion dollars
I welcome a serious conversation about
how to pay for the Investments we make
but here is what those critics are not
telling you they're not telling you that
I've committed to paying for every
single program that extended if any are
in future legislation whether that's for
a day or a decade and here's what else
I'm not telling you I'm not telling you
why it is that they're fighting so hard
against lowering the prices for
prescription drugs or child care or
Elder Care Health Care
why it is that they're so frightened
so hard to fighting so incredibly hard
to protect the 2017 Trump tax cuts that
increase the deficit Alone by nearly two
trillion dollars the bulk of which went
to large corporations and virtually none
of it paid for
I'm happy to have that debate on about
how to pay for these priorities
and my bill back better plan
we're already undoing some of the most
Reckless elements of the Trump tax bill
like ending the tax breaks for companies
sending jobs overseas you gotta you got
a tax cut for sending the job overseas
other tax giveaways in the bill that
expire that bill expires in 2025 has to
be reauthorized
for example
a tax rate for the one percent
wealthiest Americans used to be 39.6
percent you make it sound they make it
sound like it used to be 70 or something
39.6 what it was in the Bush
Administration the Trump tax cut cut
that to 37 just by restoring
that tax back to 39.7 what it was in the
bush years just by doing that would
generate an additional 20 billion
dollars a year in Revenue enough to pay
for Universal preschool for all three
and four years
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to the wealthiest one percent of the
taxpayers and we keep lowering costs for
Working Families you know we I think we
have something like 730 some
billionaires in America
that's fine you make a billion dollars
because I'm I'm okay with that but
you know what you know how much money
when everybody was losing my money
during the recession the pre-recession
you know how much money those
739 I think it is made
another trillion dollars right you hear
me now
those 735 or whatever the number is made
an additional trillion dollars in that
year and a half
trillion
I didn't hear anybody weeping the
national teeth
about any of that
if they want to argue about continuing
tax cuts for big corporations wealthiest
Americans more important than lowering
the cost of child care lowering
prescription drug prices that's an
argument I'm happy to have
I'm looking forward to that debate in
all seriousness guys it's insane that
800 people are watching on the official
White House channel
and 3 000 people are watching on our
YouTube channel never mind the other
platforms like that I don't know what it
must mean something but it's not great
and I was in 17 000 miles of them in
China
you turned to me in one of our many
one-on-one meetings with an interpreter
each
and asked me said can you define America
for me
I said yes and one word
possibilities think about it no other
nation in the world one of the reasons
why we think we're ugly America is no
other nation in the world believes that
anything we set our minds to we can do
is calling we've never failed
folks
we didn't come this nation we know
by dreaming small
throughout our history we've emerged
from crisis by investing in ourselves
during and after the Civil War we bought
during the Civil War started the
Transcontinental Railroad uniting the
east coast and the West Coast
during the Cold War we built the
interstate highway system transformed
how Americans live their lives
and now we're going to build an economy
of the 21st Century
I truly believe that 50 years from now
and I mean this from the bottom of my
heart please historians are going to
look back in this moment and the next
several years
and they're going to say
that this was the moment when America
won the competition for the 21st century
because if we don't
we're going to lose it we're going to
lose it
so folks there's nothing we can't do
when the American people set their mind
to something there's never been anything
we cannot do
there's never been a crisis we've gone
into
that we haven't come out stronger than
before we're going to do it that's who
we are
that's America
oh God bless you all may God protect
your troops and thanks for your patience
there it is folks
[Music]
very very powerful we have so much to go
over
I do hope that you guys will stick
around we've got to talk about the
shooting we're going to play Hassan or
pokemane
um we're gonna be looking at so many
different things I do want to say thanks
to Inez Williamson who made a patreon
pledge during Joe Biden's speech patreon
counts twice today putting us at 13.
also a huge thank you to shot X Thomas
hippie chick Lord labrand and Mazer bow
for the twitch Prime subscriptions it's
a beautiful day as ever
to uh well re-up that twitch Prime
subscription
go by very strongly speaking to folks
he's got a hand on his back no one's
like tapping his back kind of weird
[Music]
right
anybody know if this is a live band or
if they pump the music in
I genuinely have no idea
I think we're done with that all right
let's move on so
um sadly
there was a shooting another shooting
today okay and this one was at a school
it is believed that
um
we we really don't know the death toll
here is some reporting on this let's
start kind of going through it you know
another day in the United States right
this is the overhead scene of where this
went down this is Oxford High School
about 12 55 p.m we understand uh one
suspect one person with a gun apparently
opened fire inside of the high school
not clear what part of the high school
where this was taking place but inside
of Oxford High School we know that that
person with a handgun opened fire
at least striking four to six people we
know that four to six people had been
hurt not clear if those are students
faculty staff of this
um here is a message about the status of
the subject suspect perpetrator who is
in custody but not saying anything the
suspect fired multiple shots there's
multiple victims uh it's unfortunate I
have to report that we have three
deceased victims right now who are all
believed to be students we have six
others that were shot one was a school
teacher they're all local hospitals
being treated for various injuries
um again about multiple shots were fired
he did not give us any resistance when
he was taken into custody he's currently
being transported back to Pontiac for
potential well I he's already already
invoked his right to not speak so he
wants an attorney he's not telling us
anything at this point in time all right
so that's what we know
um a little more here yes it's a 15 year
old student who was a sophomore at the
high school as he said before he invoked
a attorney did he say anything about
what precipitated this I'm not going to
get into that
wow okay
um then here is a question to the Oxford
superintendent about school security I
really don't have any
say other than that you certainly can
pray for our families here in Oxford and
our students uh
I'm I'm learning information real time
just as you all are so I I really don't
have any more info to add any light on
who the student is a 15 year old I can't
know what's your reaction to this
well of course I'm shocked
it's devastating
superintendent can you say and spell
your name please sir Tim thrall
t-h-r-o-n-e so you had a lot of things
in place one point of entry when school
is open uh these students get Alice
training as well I know that students
and teachers are or rather teachers are
able to communicate with one another you
also have this point of safety that
you're able to get students to as well
can you talk to me about why you didn't
have metal detectors
no okay
okay that's my answer is your question
no okay is that something that's ever
come up
not that I can recall now
do you have any background information
on the student that they're getting any
issues with this student prior to today
not yet uh you know who the student is I
we don't know the name I I don't know
the names of the victims yet yeah I
don't know that family's been contacted
y'all
so I we we still got our homework to do
let us go do it and yeah of course you
do and we know that this is difficult so
we appreciate you talking that one one
of the things superintendents it's crazy
that it's like wait you did you didn't
have metal detectors at the school
that's crazy obviously you had a
shooting I mean it's like
it's it's it's crazy and it's not crazy
like this is so common that it starts to
be a question where it's like well
obviously you should be running all the
kids through a metal detector right sir
um what a what a crazy crazy situation
um meanwhile fox running a headline
there's a nationwide Santa shortage uh
people wanting to hire Santa up 121
available scientists however are down 10
I wonder if there is something about
that job that is leading to fewer people
wanting to be Santa I wonder if if that
job paid more you would have more people
wanting to do it I don't know it's just
I don't know enough about Santa
um to be able to say for sure so that's
all a little strange uh oh excellent
interview today with Nicholas christakis
that I would encourage many of you to
check out I wanted to look briefly he
talks about Omicron let me see if we can
find it
provisional
November the 30th about Omicron here we
go so my opinion
that's the that this variant probably is
roughly as transmissible to to somewhat
more transmissible than the Delta
variant it has a it's more intrinsically
infectious or as intrinsically
infectious as Delta approximately or
slightly more intrinsically infectious
than Delta I'm pretty confident about
that so that's bad
um the the hints in the data are that
it's probably not more deadly than Delta
we don't know for sure it's I'm not as
confident about that prediction yeah but
I think that's likely and on the
so-called immune Escape uh you know does
it evade the vaccines or not it's too
early to tell I think it it probably
significantly
reduces the efficacy of the vaccine in
terms of spreading
and somewhat reduces the efficacy of the
vaccine in terms of
killing you uh and but I'm not confident
about those assessments and it will take
a few weeks uh well we'll get some hints
within a couple of weeks from in vitro
studies and then a couple of months or
so before we begin to see
epidemiological studies that assess this
so that's the trajectory on Omicron or
as some people are referring to it
omnicron omnicron it's called The
omnicron exactly and it is sort of like
a panopticon I guess we would uh
potentially say as far as that goes
um
okay let's
um oh big thank you to Tama Jinx Monty
un and Ryan Rincon for the twitch Prime
subscriptions very much appreciate that
you can also grab a membership on my
website
joinpakman.com the coupon code today is
Obama Obama
which saves you 68 all right guys let's
play a game here's gonna be the game
okay we are going to play a game called
Hassan or pokemane Hassan or pokemane
two prominent twitch streamers I am
ready to pull up
uh their current streams they are both
stream actually let me even make sure of
that before we go forward
yes they are both streaming right now
okay so here's going to be the game we
are simultaneously going to put up a
poll on
YouTube and twitch unfortunately if you
are over on Facebook right now you're
not going to be able to participate and
it is going to be what who is doing a
more entertaining stream right now
Hassan or Pokeman now there are
obviously all sorts of factors that are
going to influence this some of you are
going to say Hassan merely because you
are in the sort of political space and
Pokeman does something else so you're
all going to say Hassan already
others are going to be
um uh maybe for reasons of uh
attractiveness and titillation you guys
are going to say well it's pokemane and
not Hassan so there's going to be all
these different factors that are going
to be you know uh uh
um problems for us but we're going to
see what the audience thinks and the
question is going to be who's more
entertaining right now who's stream
is more or which stream is more
entertaining right now and is going to
be Hassan or Pokey
okay I'm gonna try to get the exact same
how do I get a poll going on
on Twitch hold on pull
it has does he have to be done as a
prediction how do we do it
God I don't even do it I don't even know
how to do it on Twitch maybe moderators
can help me on Twitch okay and even
better for everybody saying you don't
know who they are that's exactly the
best that's exactly the best okay if you
don't know who they are you're just
gonna analyze that can someone help me
get a poll going on Twitch
slash poll okay
ah here we go okay perfect so you can
vote on either or both you know whatever
you want to do
I'm we're curious to see what the
audience will prefer okay
so Sun
Pokemon okay
uh and it'll be we'll run it for I'm not
going to start it quite yet okay first
we're gonna watch all right first we're
gonna go first let's see what is Hassan
up to right now
oh why don't we have audio okay here we
go oh why he's exactly a [ __ ] group
okay
here we go okay Hassan let's listen
what's he doing my father
my father's name is mehmed that's
literally Dr Oz's first name
like I have so many reasons to want to
like Dr Oz he's Turkish his same name as
my dad he's uh he's a prominent
turkish-american who has you know
brought great
a great [ __ ] joy and pride to Turks
all around the world you know okay let's
see now what Pokey is up to for
comparison
you upset oh my God you guys can Emma's
running for me in private rooms when I
opened my club
period I heard him I got the purple part
pictures I'm so excited how do I get
less stressed can I eat Mary's running
for me yeah
we're gonna vote soon
all right one more look at each of these
what is Hassan up to the question will
be which is more entertaining right now
the reason why I'm not going to cover it
yet is because it's a breaking news
story
I don't know enough
to go on about a Breaking News school
shooting okay do the bad taxes stop
please stop spamming to cover the
[ __ ] school shooting right yes
another school shooting just all right
and then last shot over here
it's okay
there's a guy in a city named Beau he
gives the best hugs and they're very
distressing all right everybody let's go
to the vote you can now vote and let's
see what my audience thinks about which
of these two streams is more
entertaining right now there has been
debate as to what does my audience
prefer uh there is a live poll happening
right now on Twitch there is a live poll
happening right now on YouTube as well
we are going to run it just a few
minutes
um three three minutes total you can
vote
um it's just a completely unscientific
exploration I want to say thanks to
Jeffrey Thompson who just signed up at
joinpakman.com and is a new member new
member number 21 today I really
appreciate that also thank you to actual
one and hack phooey for the twitch Prime
subscriptions Numbers 22 and 23.
also wheelie cat lady has made a twitch
Prime subscription on Twitch which I
very much appreciate we're we're voting
right now uh who my audience prefers on
the basis of today's stream uh Hassan or
Pokey
and we have about uh how much time do we
have left we're about halfway through
you can get your votes in for the time
being by about a two to one margin the
YouTube audience preferring Hassan
and by about a two to one audience the
twitch audience of preferring uh two to
one margin the twitch audience
preferring Hassan very interesting
almost exactly the same results
very close
um
remaining right there
600 people have voted on YouTube
only about 160 have voted on Twitch
still holding that two to one margin
two to one margin yeah that's if you've
heard of neither that's better it's
better if people are like this doesn't
work well I haven't heard of these
people that's good that means you have
no preconceived notion that's what we
like
the point is just there have there's
been debate among the audience as to
whether my audience is more of a Hassan
audience or a pokey audience the Audi
the argument for Hassan is that he's in
the political space they're both just
well-known streamers the counter would
be Hassan is an actual socialist I guess
I don't even know if that's true
um and so my Audi me not being a
socialist maybe it would actually be
people prefer Pokey I have no idea let's
see how long do we have to go
looks like about 30 seconds
thanks to prepare for Glory for the
twitch Prime subscription you're number
25 today I I appreciate that as well
down to about the last 20 seconds here
still by a very very strong two to one
margin Hassan ahead of Pokey on the
YouTube poll and Hassan ahead of Pokey
but by a slightly smaller margin in the
twitch poll
we should do Hassan and oh that's
interesting oh that's not a bad idea we
should do Hassan and Destiny let oh
that's not a bad idea let's see is
Destiny streaming
let's see
that's not a bad idea at all
no he's offline
he's offline so we can't really do it
we can't really do it wouldn't be fair
okay folks over on Twitch the audience
prefers Hassan over Pokey at least today
by a roughly two to one margin oh his
power went out oh that's interesting and
over on YouTube by basically the exact
same two to one margin the audience
prefers Hassan over Pokey so I don't
know what if anything we've learned from
that but we've learned something we've
learned something oh is is vouch
streaming let's take a look at that that
might be a good one to do vows oh gosh
here we go
okay let's do the exact same thing let's
run one more I think that that's
actually not a bad idea let me say we're
going to look at videos of vosh and
Hassan and see who people prefer let me
get these set up which streamer is more
entertaining today
and it will be Hassan versus vouch
uh and we will also do it over on Twitch
which streamer all right this might be
closer for my audience let's take a look
at a little bit of each of them okay
here we go yeah
sake uh with the two gifted tier one
subs artemy and pigeon are the before
and after of true uh uh except I'm just
as hairy as ever yes atan Shay has some
really good videos
um
DPAC is having you in the vs what does
that mean oh god let's get away from
that let's see what's happening here in
Austin dating [ __ ] models these like
the one of the most like famous
anti-vaxxers in the UK they were like oh
I probably [ __ ] up yeah [ __ ] this guy
he's no longer a doctor yeah get him out
of it go to him out of me yeah and then
he [ __ ] came to America and now he's
just killing it dude all right we're
gonna we're gonna where the poll has
started you can vote now anti-vax guy
we'll go back to vouch for a moment any
decades later true
uh anyway just anyway anyway yeah the
[ __ ] unrues
mod is very funny stop and live thank
you for the two gifts of tier one Subs
we need the Bing Chillin emote
yes we do need a big Chillin emote
um
that would that would be good yeah there
are a couple of emotes that we need to
add I thought all right and then back to
Hassan voting is happening new clothes
piece and then ended it by saying by the
way the empress Taylor was incredible
freaking Stitch
and to give Dr Ross the benefit of
overwhelming medical doubt he seems to
be standing by some of his claims I
actually do personally believe in the in
the items that I talk about in the show
I passionately study them I recognize
that oftentimes they don't have the
scientific Master to present as fact
that's the
all right back to vouch voting is
happening
well they're both talking about Dr Oz
picked office political candidacy oh
[ __ ] that's right I need to talk to
Gregory Hardin
I've taken forever to respond to his
email because I'm a cook uh yeah thank
you for the reminder okay I'll go back
into the archives
I uh
had to do that
Goldenrod thanks to five bucks uh dog
my computer has
my teacher got destiny on her wall W2 TF
what is this YouTube shorts why does it
look like this
hmm you DM me in a Discord vibration all
right back to Hassan country supplements
in the U.S are shockingly unregulated
there are two agencies who theoretically
oversee things the FTC and the FDA the
FTC is supposed to regulate the
marketing of supplements but by their
own admission they give great deference
to the FDA on whether a company's Health
claim can be supported the problem with
that is the FDA has little something the
science make is just flying flopping in
the air like a wet noodle sure it's like
the Coomer pick too it's it's like him
him looking at his monitor after
ejaculating for the eighth time that day
okay we're gonna have to get away from
this what is happening Destiny up on
there
a teacher has a picture of Destiny on
the wall good baby oh my God so stupid
I thought that was some kind of weird
porn for a second that was weird uh okay
back over here Congressman more people
wrote to Congress about the supplement
bill then wrote about the Vietnam War
foreign
what all right guys so between Hassan
and vouch on Twitch it has been a dead
heat 50 to 50 50 to 50 over on YouTube
Hassan easily taking it at 60 plus
percent so that's interesting that's a
difference the YouTube audience seems to
prefer Hassan whereas on Twitch it was
much much more uh mixed apparently so
that's the takeaway
um I don't know necessarily whether
we've learned anything but I sort of
hope that we have I want to say thank
you to Jen here for gifting and
resubbing very much appreciate that
numbers 26 and 27 very very important
um and okay yeah let's let's get back to
to the voicemails as we were doing
before let's see what we've got coming
in here
let's do normal voicemails sometimes
people in the audience love it when I do
normal voicemails and then you realize
there's a reason why I'm curating them
hi Mr David Pacman
um here's a question
that hopefully as busy as yours and so
many talk topics you can um let me know
okay let's talk about Mark Meadows not
to Discount Butlers because Batman had a
butler I'm trying to relate to others uh
I think his name was Alfred I'm in my
60s
have not seen the new Batman's any of
them I'm My Own realist well anyway but
um so Mark Meadows was there for a year
and he's basically the butler the
right-hand man he's the step he he takes
care of Staff people are asking to move
on all right normal voicemails normal
voicemails
we're continuing
David this is Walter Cronkite CBS News
New York
calling to let your readers know about a
new novel by Mario Vargas yosa called
Harsh Times it's a novel about the
events in Guatemala in 1954 and the U.S
role in that country
it's a companion what the hell
to Vargas yosa's magnificent 2001 novel
The Feast of the goat
once again David Mario Vargas yosa one
of the great writers of our day at 85
years old has produced a brilliant novel
about the politics of Guatemala this is
Walter Cronkite CBS News and that's the
way it is that's not bad except
cronkite's been dead for um must be 12
or 13 years or something like that so
okay that's
that's something
uh
uh geez
hey David what this is Matthew what will
happen
like worst case
it's not in the U.S
which I'm saying it's likely but let's
just say it doesn't go in the U.S
but this doesn't work against the
vaccines what will happen
you think they would end up lifting
travel bans and just letting the people
in would just say hey let's
keep it up for a little while while we
can get vaccines working and then
Republicans will go attack them thanks
so we're doing normal good voicemails
okay
um
let's see
hi David I say this with love and as a
website member you need to stop
attributing bad cakes to mental illness
I don't understand the need to do this
like whether it was you asking if it was
Destiny's autism had anything to do with
his takes or that end times preacher and
whether she was mentally ill or like on
today's show how uh Laura Logan might be
giving bad takes now because of trauma
well it's a catch-22 because if I don't
mention it then people write to me and
say I'm being hard on someone who's
clearly suffering from PTSD or whatever
so like what the caller is referring to
I can even show you what the caller is
referring to
um
today on the show I on the podcast I
played this clip okay I'll play the clip
for you now and
say to me that he doesn't represent
science to them he represents Joseph
Mengele Dr Joseph the doc the Nazi
Doctor Who did experiments on Jews
during the second world war okay now I
played this and I mentioned
I should say whenever I talk about Lara
Logan people write to me and they say
David you got to be careful criticizing
Lara Logan she was sexually assaulted
covering the Egyptian revolution in
2011.
um I don't really know the full details
of it but she is unwell and suffering
from PTSD so I mentioned I know some
people will say this and I don't know
but this is crazy Rick to say regardless
this is an outrageous thing to say
that that's what it was you know the
other one was
um the woman talking about Xerxes
uh where is it what what's her name
um n times
yeah this one okay where I said
this is this is supposedly religion but
it actually seems to me like mental
illness after Derek and I got married
one night
this other Derek
appears in our bed right the real Derek
is lying down next to me
other Derek sits right up out of him
it startled me
I knew that was not Derek
and so I asked this critter
who are you right because he clearly
wanted to have sexual relations whoa
and I said and he said come on I'm your
husband I said who are you
and he had the nerve to claim to be
like I showed this video to my dad who's
a psychiatrist and he said when patients
would come into my office with
equivalent stories except I mean not
except it wasn't religious
the only difference was it wasn't about
Jesus although sometimes it was we're
talking about very serious conditions
that we should medicate for right so I
mean delusional paranoia schizophrenia
yeah whatever we're not diagnosing her
I'll swear us
Xerxes
well other Derek seriously wanted to
invite me
to use my free will right to do
something that was going to pull me away
from God
you used to just say I have a headache
but she's come up with something
different
so this last time
I knew
he was really desperate
and I asked him again who are you he
told me the same answer and I said I'm
not going with you this was an internal
dialogue finally I said I've had enough
in my mind I reached up
I grabbed his face right and I said you
are a liar
and Jesus is real and I pulled that face
off okay and then she goes on to talk
about gargoyles so it's like the caller
is saying don't attribute bad takes to
mental illness that seems like more than
a bad take but let's listen to the end
of it and the the uh during her coverage
of the Egyptian revolution
um I understand a lot of these people
have absolutely wacky out of this world
takes but I just see no reason why we
should throw mental illness or try to
diagnose people on the spot and say that
their bad takes are related to what we
think their mental illnesses yeah I mean
listen so when I don't do it people
write in and they say David you're
you're analyzing something like that's
anything other than a delusional person
or a sick person so then I do say also
we might want to consider this and then
people write in or they call in and they
say you shouldn't be doing that either
in my business you can't please
everybody no matter what people get mad
when I talked about
um when I talked about Kyle
rittenhouse's mom and the interview she
gave initially I didn't say anything
about her mental state then all these
people are in they go David
you're criticizing the the speech of a
cognitively limited woman and I said I
have no evidence that she's cognitively
Limited
and then when I mentioned this the
second time I mentioned and some people
wrote it and said this then I got people
writing and saying David you shouldn't
have mentioned that because there's no
evidence of it
okay that's a life lesson folks you
can't please everybody that's what it is
all right a couple more normal
voicemails
um I do want to say thanks to Blueberry
babe Manny bionic Bill
ASW and elevated disc golf for the
twitch Prime Subs twitch is doing the
heavy lifting today the website
memberships are not keeping up there
under the bargain
um Okay let's listen to a couple other
normal
voicemails
hey David I'm a big fan of the show
um recently I heard your interview with
Andrew Yang
um I heard he recently kind of called
you out I don't think he was calling you
out as much as he was
um pulling out the people who clipped
the video and posted it to him on
Twitter
um I think he still likes you okay
um now I voted for the guy in the
primary back in 2020.
um
or 2019 as it was
um
okay all right good well yeah we said
that that's certainly a uh possibility
um
okay let's go to another just no we're
not we're not curating these just going
back to back
come on David Daryl from Connecticut
giving you a call I want to give a big
shout out to producer Pat to you as well
um pretty hilarious if you go to the
member content on your website uh you
have your daily videos and bonus shows
posted if you scroll quickly all the
thumbnails of you David in the different
animations of your facial expressions
liking a lot to the many faces of
Charles Manson if you if you Google
there's an animated gif of and making
like yeah it's it's a joke like we we
deliberately pick
um just funny funny thumbnails of me
yeah they're all they're all we're
picking like basically the funniest
thumbnail by the way this is the member
platform where if you're a member you
get all of this great stuff commercial
free feeds and the bonus showing all
this different stuff yeah we we tend to
do
um we we it's it's the could my mouth
possibly be any wider open in some of
these
um
that was a good one oh my God and the
mustache yeah it's an ongoing joke and
we love it so I'm glad that you've
noticed that but it is it is absolutely
deliberate okay let's do a couple of
others here hey David Eric from Mass uh
you believe in coincidences so here's a
pretty good one same day Omicron has
announced is when the Elaine Maxwell sex
trafficking trial stats wow almost like
it was deliberate yeah because it was
just a coincidence all right I don't
even think that that's accurate like I
think Omicron
the first big Omicron day was Friday and
didn't the trial start yesterday so it's
not it's not even the same day
how many is too many for you
get another booster brother another
booster
yeah maybe I will
maybe I will
here's another call
and answer to your question Joe Biden
will not run for re-election because
he's not doing well right now and I
don't mean the fact that he's failed to
to deliver economically
he also is failing his health he looks
like he's aging rapidly before my eyes
presidents tend to prove year one yet
no he's not Rick he's not running for
the election and if he did no one would
vote for him he'd be too [ __ ] old and
he's proven himself to be ineffective
he and the Democratic party are done as
far as I'm concerned are done unless by
some miracle Pelosi and Schumer resign
or they retire I don't know what's up
with this guy's phone call he always is
clipping and there's like a kind of like
a like a electrical hum
or they step down and become regular
senators and they help to put in their
leadership role people that are
aggressive Progressive like ilhan Omar
but she used to leave Alexandria Castle
Cortez or someone like that
failing that the party's done and this
country is done we will become a fascist
state so prepare your uh
your passport David bye-bye prepare my
passport an ominous warning I want to
say thanks to Senor pants Twisted Hawk
Drake and Jay Putnam for the twitch
Prime subscriptions putting us at 36 a
beautiful number let's see what else
we've got here
[Music]
um
okay
oh my God I don't I don't know if you
can hear me I was uh retire in Chicago
but now I'm in Vegas but sir you
wouldn't believe I'm staying with a
bunch of other veterans
and you wouldn't believe the the Apache
what anyway I was called the heated
yesterday because
I doubted
God inspired writing I I doubted it
because
any anybody can say that anyway you say
that at any time that inspired me like
this got inspired me to this there's no
factual or scientific data behind it
but it's just [ __ ] drove me through
it just it went to like an hour-long
discussion anybody understanding this is
this guy calling from an airport that's
this guy was in his 50s I I think it's
just a waiting game I think the waiting
game until the older people just die out
I don't want
I'm just saying eventually they're gonna
die it's just a winning game it's it's
called Evolution David tackling
hey you know what they're gonna all
right
um we got the next one is from Whitney
so on issues where you say that the
rights does not care
if it's not happening to them
okay
here's the thing is be careful what you
wish for because the right will come
over and regulate and it's not going to
be in the way that you want them to but
they do care
they just don't have the authority yet
to do so so if you keep holding them up
like oh man I don't know what she's
talking about I do want to say thanks to
Jay gal and Dr gecko however new members
number 37 and 38 today as well all right
everybody we've covered it all we've
covered the Biden stuff we've covered
the Omicron and omnicron we've covered
the shooting we've taken voicemails
we've looked at memes and all sorts of
different things I want to sign off for
the month this is it for the month of
November no more streaming unfortunately
I will see everybody very very soon in
the month of December we are going to do
a very very powerful raid over on Twitch
we will man I don't even know who to
raid
um I guess uh
We're not gonna do a raid right now all
right thanks everybody we're gonna see
you all very very